[Musica]
mi sono cacciato nei guai nel accettare
di parlare del what's next del futuro
della formazione qui a cortina per tre
motivi 1 perché arrivò dopo questo
magnifico intervento di affinati due
perché l'innovazione nell'educazione e
nella formazione è un tema molto
frequentato nel circuito di ted
sono sicuro che da qua due minuti
comincerete a fare il confronto tra la
mia specie quella famosissima di ken
robinson quei suoi 50 milioni di
visualizzazioni però non so che dirvi
farò del mio meglio
il terzo motivo è che il dibattito sulla
formazione la sua innovazione e
incomprensibile si dice tutto e il
contrario di tutto
c'è chi sostiene che nell'economia della
conoscenza a quella in cui viviamo
quella dei servizi quella dei lavori ad
alta intensità di creatività quella
dell'innovazione studiare sia importante
lo sia sempre di più ma che vada fatto
in modi radicalmente diversi rispetto a
quanto abbiamo saputo fare nel sistema
educativo tradizionale bisogna si dice
non più concentrarsi sulla trasmissione
di conoscenze e nozioni ma dare ai
nostri giovani ai nostri ragazzi
le competenze del xxi secolo la
risoluzione dei problemi in capacità di
lavorare in gruppo addomesticarli quasi
alle dinamiche che troveranno nel mondo
del lavoro appena finiranno i propri
studi
d'altronde i saperi fondamentali nella
matematica della fisica delle lettere
della storia li possiamo trovare
gratuitamente su internet in enormi
portali pieni di video lezioni
dall'altra parte ci sono i pessimisti
quelli che sostengono che studiare non
serva più di tanto e che studiare troppo
sia addirittura inutile
alcuni numeri sembrano dare loro ragione
vi cito alcune cifre giusto per darvi la
dimensione nell'economia americana
si calcola che solo il 20 per cento dei
nuovi posti di lavoro creati richiedono
una laurea la gran parte dei nuovi posti
di lavoro che vengono creati richiedono
un diploma di scuola media superiore
addirittura titoli a di livello più
basso c'è un'altra statistica che mi
colpisce tantissimo che dice che per
ogni posto di lavoro da programmatore da
sviluppatore che viene creato ne vengono
creati altri tre
per individui che vadano a far saltare
gli hamburger di mcdonald's david gray
bear un'importante antropologo inglese
ha fatto un'analisi impietosa del
mercato del lavoro di oggi ha visto che
ci sono milioni di individui molto
preparati che svolgono mansioni
ripetitive lavori sostanzialmente privi
di senso inutili e sono consapevoli del
fatto che il loro mestiere non dà alcun
contributo all'umanità
lui li chiama con un'etichetta piuttosto
come dire efficace bush jobs lavori di
merda ora in questo dibattito io come
persona che nell'educazione nella
formazione ci lavora quotidianamente mi
sento in difficoltà ci sono centinaia di
voci più o meno autorevoli che dicono
che quello che faccio non serve andrebbe
fatto in modo radicalmente diverso che i
luoghi in cui lo faccio andrebbero rasi
al suolo e reinventati però vi dico
anche che negli ultimi anni come dire
avendo fede nella mia azione ho
riflettuto molto su che cosa significa
fare didattica su che cosa significa
insegnare
ho praticato il nuovo e lo mescolato con
quello di buono che c'è ed è tanto ve lo
garantisco del vecchio mi sono
soprattutto confrontato con decine
centinaia di colleghi nella mia
università in altre università e in
istituti scolastici di diverso ordine e
grado
e vi dirò una cosa la formazione del
futuro è già qui anzi la formazione che
prepara i giovani al nostro futuro è qui
e ora e la stiamo praticando in tanti ve
la racconto prendendo spunto da
un'esperienza personale e tuttavia
distillando anche quello che ha imparato
parlando con queste persone questi miei
colleghi che ho incontrato durante
questo percorso
la mia esperienza personale e quella di
aver costruito coordinato un laboratorio
all'università ca foscari che si chiama
active learning lab
noi prendiamo degli studenti che
arrivano da tutte le nostre diverse
lauree discipline umanistiche
scientifiche economica li mettiamo
insieme e li mettiamo di fronte a delle
aziende enti pubblici o anche
manifestazioni della società civile che
chiedono loro di affrontare delle sfide
molto ambizioso e molto lungimiranti in
sei settimane in questi studenti sono
chiamati a mobilitare
le conoscenze che hanno acquisito nei
loro percorsi di studio ea creare delle
soluzioni innovative ecco a partire da
questa sperimentazione ma ve lo ripeto
sono davvero tante e non solo coordinate
da me è chiaramente mi sento di
distillare il ritratto della formazione
non del futuro ma della formazione che
qui e ora prepara i nostri giovani al
futuro questo ritratto lo farò
utilizzando tre obiezioni 3
contrapposizioni che ricorrono molto
spesso nel dibattito sull'educazione
sulla formazione la prima è la
pericolosissima a mio avviso
contrapposizione tra conoscenza emozioni
da una parte e competenze dall'altra
l'idea che la scuola debba rinunciare al
conservare e trasmettere alle nuove
generazioni i saperi che abbiamo
accumulato in decenni e secoli di
ricerca di riflessione umanistica per
insegnare la creatività il problem
solving la trovo pericolosa per due
motivi il primo io sono un volatore
nervoso un nervo flyer e ogni volta che
sono su un aereo 10 chilometri d'altezza
non c'è creatività che regga io spero
vivamente che chi ha progettato
quell'aereo fosse ossessivamente padrone
delle leggi della fisica delle leggi del
volo e delle leggi che governano le
perturbazioni la creatività senza il
possesso dei fondamentali delle nozioni
le chiameremo rischia di essere uno
sfoggio inutile è possibile sia arrivare
a delle soluzioni esercitando la
creatività salvo poi scoprire che
qualcuno c'era arrivato prima di noi la
scuola poi in un po la scuola il sistema
educativo non possono più rinunciare
oggi sono di fronte alla sfida
gigantesca non possono più rinunciare a
trasmettere i saperi che abbiamo
accumulato nel tempo perché noi tutti
insieme respiriamo condividiamo
l'ossigeno di questa terra con milioni
di individui che oggi nel 2017 credono a
complotti di ogni tipo pensano ancora
che la terra sia piatta hanno creduto al
metodo stamina e non hanno la più
pallida differenza della la più pallida
idea della differenza che intercorre tra
coincidenza e causalità non ce lo
possiamo più permettere
certo insegnare le nozioni i saperi va
adeguato ai tempi
certo è importante raccordarli con la
realtà anche perché i nostri giovani
imparino quali sono le condizioni di
validità dei saperi
non ci sono grandi rivoluzioni da fare
non serve gettare il cuore oltre
l'ostacolo è facile ve lo dico da qui
questo signore qui si chiama kevin
parker insegna harvard lui è nato nel
south carolina e li hanno un'ossessione
il barbecue per loro una regione lo
insegna ai fondamenti della fisica della
chimica harvard chiedendo ai propri
studenti di progettare il barbecue in
grado di cucinare la bistecca perfetta
perfetta in termini di duratura
superficiale morbidezza gusto e sapore
lo fanno progettano dei barbecue mentre
imparano come funziona la cottura anche
nei nostri laboratori a ca foscari
succedono cose analoghe ai nostri
studenti è stato chiesto di ricavare
qualche cosa di nuovo da degli scarti di
lavorazione del caffè hanno sorpreso le
imprese tirando fuori delle palline in
grado di separare per esempio materiali
oleosi e acqua per decontaminare dei
siti hanno creato sempre dagli scarti
del caffè delle di una polverina
esplosiva non l'abbiamo provata in aula
volevo evitare i titoli dei giornali
fino a 8 fa esplodere ca foscari però
validata fuori funzionato quindi si
tratta di trovare un equilibrio tra il
sapere e l'accompagnare al saper fare la
seconda contrapposizione è quella tra il
fisico e il digitale tra l'individuale e
il sociale l'idea che noi possiamo
imparare qualsiasi cosa gratuitamente e
democraticamente tirando giù dei video
da internet e affascinante ma pericolosa
la ricerca pedagogica negli ultimi 30
anni ha dimostrato chiaramente che si
impara e si crea nuova conoscenza
condividendo luoghi fisici creando
relazioni anche emotivamente molto
impegnative essendo sicuri dei propri
saperi ma essendo disposti a farsi
sorprendere a imparare tramite i saperi
degli altri
la sfida quindi che abbiamo e noi per
esempio ca foscari mettendo insieme
studenti ricercatori imprenditori
esperti e tecnici in questi laboratori è
quella di andare oltre la scuola e
l'università come sistemi chiusi in
delle classi e creare delle comunità che
innovano e apprende
insieme ciascuno sicuro dei suoi saperi
ma ciascuno disposto a imparare dagli
altri
l'ultima opposizione su cui mi volevo
soffermare che la più importante badate
bene è quella che c'è tra autonomia e
docilità lo confesso anche se io sono un
professore di economia
lo confesso che ogni volta che sento
dire che la scuola e l'università
dovrebbero preparare al lavoro
impauriscono sento troppo spesso dire
che dovremmo far imparare ai nostri
studenti i mestieri che servono alle
imprese oggi mi sento meno spesso dire
che il nostro compito è quello di
formare dei giovani preparati affamati
in grado di prendere organizzazioni
amministrazioni pubbliche
la società nel suo complesso e rivoltare
tutto come un calzino per prepararlo al
futuro eppure pensateci io li vedo i
ragazzi quando sono in aula sono
sottoposti a centinaia di stimoli
mescolano ciò che sanno con ciò che
apprendono e che arriva da mondi diversi
dalla ricerca che viene fatta negli
stati uniti in cina in india e altrove
sono in altre parole il ponte più
efficace tra l'oggi e il domani però la
differenza la facciamo noi noi educatori
e noi come società quali sono le nostre
aspettative ci aspettiamo che occupino
un posticino in un gioco già definito ci
aspettiamo dio vogliamo dare loro il
margine per costruirlo il loro futuro
ora con queste tre contrapposizioni in
modo molto veloce vi ho dato i tre
elementi che mi consentono di creare il
ritratto di quella che credo sia
l'educazione che prepara al futuro e che
esiste qui e ora creare un equilibrio
tra il sapere è accompagnare al saper
fare creare delle comunità che imparano
insieme andando oltre la scuola il
sistema educativo come sistema chiuso
avere anche l'umiltà di insegnare ai
nostri giovani l'ardire di pensare che
il mondo non è dato che il loro futuro
non è dato ma che lo possono costruire
ora io non vi so dire se per trovare
lavoro e soprattutto per essere felici
nel prossimo futuro i nostri giovani
debbano studiare la matematica la fisica
le lettere il coding o qualsiasi altra
cosa vada di moda però come non lo so io
ho fidatevi non lo sanno in tanti il
futuro come sempre è indecifrabile
illeciti
quando si parla di educazione invece a
me piace sempre ritornare alla poesia
che amo tantissimo scritta da una figura
che ammiro tantissimo danilo dolci
secondo cui l'educazione e il far
crescere le persone è una questione di
sogno
abbiamo la responsabilità di far
crescere i nostri giovani sognando le
come li dobbiamo sognare la nostra
responsabilità è quella di vederli nel
loro futuro in prima battuta come
individui e cittadini competenti
responsabili non tecnici docili in
seconda battuta dobbiamo sognarli come
individui appassionati che mettono al
lavoro i propri saperi e che insieme
rinnovano il mondo in cui vivono in cui
lavorano in cui si amano e stanno
insieme ad altre persone in terza
istanza dobbiamo sognarli come individui
che davvero nel mondo lo vogliono
scomporre e ricomporre come pare e piace
a loro o comunque come ritengono sarà
giusto piuttosto che vederli sgomitare
tra di loro per occupare una casella in
una scacchiera che abbiamo già
rigidamente definito ecco questa scuola
questa università non del futuro a ma
che prepara i giovani al futuro è qui
e l'invito è quella di andarlo a
visitare a vedere perché capirete e
vedrete che le sperimentazioni di questo
tipo sono tantissime
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]